à bonsoir bonsoir déjà j'ai un truc à
vous montrer c'est ça c'était une
sculpture de moins pâte à modeler très
stylé et maintenant on dirait un
youtuber blessés dans une flaque de sang
voilà avec une jambe cassée j'ai fait
faire ça au mexique ça je suis dégoûté a
précédent le thème des stades au regard
des jeux mais le décor nickel écouter
aujourd'hui on va faire la suite d'un
subside qu'on a tous adoré à tel point
que c'est la vidéo la plus vue de
l'année dernière sur la chaîne youtube
one single be faut disait ce bon gros
lot globalement les profs d'anglais pas
mais vidéo c'est par gramme par contre
l'espanyol je vous dis je vois du
mexique là chut c'est bon je suis
vraiment élevé de l'espagnol binz hockey
et c'est tant mieux oui ce serait dit
souvenez vous c'est des vidéos où
globalement il va se passer un truc pas
cool pour quelqu'un dans la vidéo mais
ça s'arrête juste avant donc tout va
bien à youtube si vous adorez les
démonétisé les sabres il dit c'est parce
que j'ai cassé le trophée 10 millions
[Musique]
youtube d'ailleurs ils ont envoyé pour
remercier les créateurs à la en fin 2021
un espèce de petit nftc un petit objet
dans lequel il ya un écran par exemple
sabila eu celui là
un peu style est quand même un peu style
et moi j'ai eu ça
ça ne bouge même pas d'accord c'est nul
youtube j'ai compris qu'il ya une petite
tension entre vous et moi venez on va
boire un verre on fait un truc bref il
ya eu beaucoup de nouveaux postes sur ce
saut brigite et on va sentir bien c'est
vraiment sérieux tu te sens bien à la
fin déjà qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel pourquoi une femme dort en au
premier plan pourquoi il ya un obstacle
s'il ya plein de questions que je me
pose
[Musique]
j'ai eu l'oeil noir ben
j'espère pas c'est une fin de carrière
bon claquer le cul de sa mère très
mauvaise idée est très bizarre aussi à
la fois et ensuite lui là il rêve d'un
fils unique c'est pas possible c'est
quoi ce piège là c'est pour l'héritage
qu'est ce que c'est que ça vous n'êtes
pas censés vous soutenir entre frères je
comprends pas chrisf oct alors qu'est ce
que c'est que ça
[Musique]
mais qu on sent qu'il est envoûté par
cette sirène elle c'est simple c'est le
truc que ya dans le flou de l'image dans
les films d'horreur vous savez ya
l'acteur au premier plan il ya un truc
dans le flou l'image qui fait peur c'est
elle s'appelait forme comptage clément
oh non non non non non ça c'est horrible
mec je sais ça me rappelle une gaffe un
crabe est mignonne parce qu'elle a été
faite par un enfant de quitter united à
l'époque au téléthon où il chante du
coup il fait une presta et pendant
qu'ils chantent il s'emporte t il dit un
truc il faut pas dire à des gens en
fauteuil roulant
bah là je pensais la même chose en
peut-être pire regarde on
n'a pas de bras ça se voit à les manches
pendent fait un effort que tu sois fait
un effort très très cool la shdm et j'ai
bien aimé avec le petit flash
wahaha ya que des trucs terribles dégâts
heureusement je sais que ça peut pas
être gore parce que ça s'arrête pile
avant mai
[Musique]
il ya un petit délai le temps clooney
renvoi signal au cerveau là il est là le
signal il en est là il est pas encore
arrivé là ça soit fait attention avec ça
vous savez que chaque année il ya
beaucoup de gens blessés voire mort à
cause de ça qui se filment devant des
trains qui passent ils regardent leurs
caméras exactement comme lui se rendent
pas compte de la distance et ils se font
chouchouter par le train voilà le poids
d'un train s'affiche à l'écran génique
et l'ambiance qu'est ce que tu fais
raccoon a gelé vue je les ai vus et
c'est franchement c ette
durera pas bien un galaxy 3 la grippe ah
lalala lalala se tenir coller à des gens
qui lancent des trucs louches halal
alors
[Musique]
mes testicules viennent de remonter les
y'a personne n'est resté insensible face
à ce drame j'espère qu'il veut un
article dans un journal local quel
couple adorable
il est mignon
[Musique]
c'est excellent c'est typiquement la
réaction que j'aurais à sa place je vous
jure en veine ya globalement 3 % de
chances pour qu'il est vraiment
quelqu'un dans le truc est à 97 % de
chances pour que j'ai un vieux feeling
basé sur rien donc autant met une grosse
droit demont bouche ça revient
statistiquement il a raison ag japonais
ça faisait longtemps géré mater
takeshi's castle n'ya pas longtemps
c'est incroyable un des meilleurs jeux
[ __ ] qui ait jamais existé
[Musique]
ainsi en mode spiegel
créé aux douces et homologué ça comme je
j'ai jamais compris d'où ça vient mais
je crois que culturellement ils ont un
truc le japon avec le sm le
sadomasochisme ya plein de jeter les
japonais comme ça ou quand la personne
du père l1 châtiments physiques de fou
même à l'époque silent librairie le tri
dans la bibliothèque lac a été repris
partout dans le monde quand tu regardes
le challenge c'est essentiellement des
trucs physiques qui font mal ils ont un
vrai délire avec sale japonais c'est ouf
hausse et des claques doigts j'adore
c'est merdique
il est très fier
[Musique]
ce mec sa bru faut pas faire ça ne fait
pas ça en revanche s'est transformée
mercredi la non là il est à deux doigts
de jean la faille de l'invocateur et de
gangs aux bottes je joue beaucoup trop à
league of legend en ce moment ça chez
nous à avec donne sur l'éclat gloire ça
s'appelle claque doigt parce qu'à la
base c'est fait pour exploser entre deux
doigts
chef alors au début ça fait hyper peur
et pourtant je vous jure qu'on faisait
un claque doit serrer le très fort entre
vos deux doigts là il va exploser vous
aurez rien et c'est pour ça qu'ils
s'appellent un claque doit en revanche
ne lançait pas de claques doigt sur le
visage de vos amis sinon ça
s'appellerait un claque visage et sa
free qui fait que les japonais et qu'il
n'est venue du sexe qu'audacieux shakhla
à oui c'est ça qui détecte tous cas aux
avants tôt
[Musique]
sybase à bagram c'est un bug je crois je
les gars je crois que c'est une tranche
à la fin de cette vidéo on n'aura plus
jamais envie de franck et qui que ce
soit a encore tourné mal sinon ce serait
pas sur sa brigitte
[Musique]
mais cette réaction mais on est où là et
pas une catcheuse mexicaine a well elle
a fait beaucoup de sport de combat ne
sortez jamais quelqu'un qui fait les
sports de combat voilà c'est fini c'est
vrai que ce soit
wall et rob freer au il a fait un truc
m'a déjà un objet d'en parler ce gars
est clairement le sosie de pid davidson
regarder on dirait le même gars et il ya
un truc particulier avec ce gars c'est
que 100% des meufs le trouve méga beau
et 100% des mecs le trouve absolument
pas beau et il ya peut-être un lien
peut-être un lien quoi qu'il en soit
l'aigreur de sept femmes dépassent toute
la twittosphère je n'ai jamais vu ça
comment c'est possible d'être aussi
vénère parce qu'un mec vlog elle lui a
mis une main et au cou elle s'est prise
pour hitachi la bâtarde c'était sa duc
et le mec là ok qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est vrai sauf quand
[Musique]
quoi j'ai essayé de péter discrètement
dans la bonbonne à oxygène de ma grand
mère mais h et respecte la vraie est
trop bien mais vidéo plutôt lieu sur des
trucs comme ça
[Musique]
ben moi il me faut juste un prout et je
suis au sol j'en ai marre 25 ans frérot
25 ans or on arrête tout nouvelle preuve
entre couples
[Musique]
watts en lui c'est trop l'eau de javel
rideau de douche tu vois il savait pas
lui
ah mais c'est ça qui a dans le vaccin ah
mais c'est sa faveur alors blague à part
à mes amis donnent anecdotes guise de
générique là il ya des bouteilles
d'alcool ou deux dents il ya des
insectes morts le chef y en a avec des
scorpions y en a avec des serpents j'ai
vu ça au mexique ça me dégoûte à salé on
l'a déjà vu mais allez culte pourquoi
parce que surtout parce que sa tête pour
la forme du ballon de foot quand on me
tire dedans
on en a déjà parlé mais les piscines à
vagues le nombre d'accidents et de morts
qui a eu dans des piscines à vagues
c'est une dingue mais vous avez quand
même plus de chances de mourir de la
coulisse les mecs resteront des mecs non
les gars non vous ne faites pas honneur
là qu'est ce que c'est acheter au
monopoly [ __ ]
moi
on
[Musique]
méritait les filles je vous jure on
s'amuse pas tous avec des petites
cuillers dans notre bouche à se mettre
des coups je vous jure c'est promis même
quand vous n'êtes pas là on fait pas ça
je vous assure garder un peu d'estimé
pour nous s'il vous plaît oh non c'est
un chat qui traquent un au nom à
l'étranger non il est adorable j'espère
c'est pour ça que j'aime pas les chasser
des chasseurs nez ils sont trop forts
mettons le tout sans photo de profil
pour lui rendent hommage juste 24 heures
s'il vous plaît il le mérite il était au
rapid à jumbo je vais engueuler jumbo
pour la peine de mort eh bien les amis
c'est la fin de cette vidéo et j'ai pris
mon pied c'est vraiment un classique
sobrie dit ou temaru a pris ya pas mal
de trucs que je vous épargne qui sont
full fake très bien fait les mecs se
donne beaucoup de mal pour faire mal
mais moi j'avoue conséquent c'est pas
naturel ça ne fait pas rire c'est ce que
remarquée sur la pierre tombale on se
retrouve bientôt dans d'autres vidéos il
ya plein de vidéos tournées en ailleurs
qu'ici qui arrive sur la chaîne des
concepts plus ou moins gros j'espère que
toutes ces vidéos là vous plairont il y
en aura beaucoup plus qu'habituellement
dans les mois à venir donc voilà je suis
très hype et par ça allez je retourne
jouer à league of legends je suis
complètement addict allez du balai
circuler là
je vous engage
[Musique]